[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous faire
découvrir un film méconnu injustement
méconnu la révolution silencieuse de
l'allemand l'arthroom c'est un film qui
est sorti en 2018 juste avant le
confinement autant dire que il n'a pas
bien été distribué et pourtant il est du
niveau de ses grands films allemands
comme la vie des autres ou goodbye
Lénine la révolution silencieuse c'est
l'histoire de 19 jeunes lycéens d'une
classe d'une petite ville d'Allemagne de
l'Est on est six ans avant la
construction du mur et ces Allemands de
l'Est picousaient au régime soviétique
vont se montrer solidaire dé hongrois
qui se révoltent à Budapest ils vont
simplement imposer une minute de silence
dans leur classe et le film la
révolution silencieuse aborde toutes les
conséquences de cette minute de silence
et c'est là que l'histoire devient
passionnante parce qu'en traitant ce
sujet le réalisateur aborde la question
de l'engagement et des conséquences de
ses actes et voilà pourquoi la
révolution silencieuse est un grand film
qui nous fait réfléchir tout en nous
captivant l'histoire est remarquable
elle va par pallier successifs mené à
des conséquences importantes et le
générique final nous montrera que
l'aventure est belle pour tous ces
jeunes c'est un film très intéressant
pour les adultes comme pour les jeunes
lycéens je vous le recommande vivement
l'artz chromer 2018 la révolution
silencieuse c'est à voir dès que vous
pouvez
[Musique]